usually it's my dad and I were kind of
the dream team Cameron Boyce's dad and
mom are remembering their late son who
died earlier this month
sharing sweet personal photos of Cameron
[Music]
Cameron's younger sister Maya also
shared a heart-wrenching tribute writing
in part he always said that if you have
a voice you have the privilege of using
that voice for change and he did not
take that idea lightly he understood his
responsibility as someone so many kids
would look up to today I brought my
sister she was excited about it so this
is one of the first events that we've
come to together Cameron died in his
sleep from a seizure on July 6 his
family later told ET the 20 year old
suffered from epilepsy
Cameron's larger-than-life personality
made him a standout in projects like
Jessie and The Descendants trilogy
Cameron said we can't take it with us so
it's about what you leave and and with
this I promise Cameron that I will carry
this goodness with me in all the days of
my life
et spoke with descendants director Kenny
Ortega last week about Cameron's legacy
I gotta say you did bring up Cameron
Boyce how do you think the third
descendents movie is really gonna pay
tribute to him well it does everything
that Cameron's in he brings the light
every every room that he walked into
every cause that he that he did you know
pushed for and everything that he ever
did I mean he was it was impossible not
to be drawn into him that's how I found
him I fell in love with him when he was
doing Jessie and I went after him for
descendants oh yes oh yes and so
descendants three you know again we'll
just remind everybody of his incredible
gift you know he was bioluminescent he
was lit from the inside out he really
was and and we will miss him but we will
carry his legacy forward
[Music]
[Applause]
you